a lot of news to cover tonight joining
us now with reaction two of the
lawmakers that sign the criminal
referral letter today congressman Ron de
Santos Florida and Matt Gaetz thank you
both for being with us congressman to
Santos to me this has been a long time
building this has been a long time
coming so often we hear the Attorney
General say there's a process if I get a
referral I'll look into it
they now have not only the referral but
the specific laws that you believe and I
believe were violated in each case well
that's right Sean and he has this guy
Huber who we now know he's appointed and
I want to make sure that people like
Huber know that these are in this is
information that Congress has developed
it's been in the public square and then
to focus on this stuff because you have
situations where combing he's out on
this book tour acting like his values
trombe all but yet he testified in front
of the Congress that he didn't exonerate
Hillary until after the interview when
we know evidence has come out that he
exonerated her two months before with
the memo then you look at somebody like
Andrew McCabe he rushed in the prosecute
Michael Flynn they went in they
interviewed Flynn and in in prosecute
him for false statement McCabe lied to
the FBI it's documented now multiple
times is there a different set of rules
for McCabe this is all about equal
application of the law well think about
this I mean when when Meghan McCain
actually asked Comey today about oh well
I lie I've told some of my lies in the
book and Angele you can still lie and be
a good person like Andrew McCabe I'm
saying wait a minute does that apply to
general Michael Flynn who was charged
with lying to the FBI
congressman gates Sean if lies where
music Jim Comey would be Beethoven but
when you lie to Congress it's a crime
when you leak information that's
classified it's a crime and when you
allow your personal politics to dictate
the outcome of an investigation before
even conducting the investigation in
earnest that could be obstruction of
justice and so in Congress we didn't
want to just sit around and hope that
Jeff Sessions and others would seriously
look into these matters we wanted to
specifically detail the violations of
law and
demand action from our Attorney General
because we cannot allow this to stand
the director of the FBI James Comey
fired the deputy director Andrew McCain
here's the fire boom struck fired and
reassigned it's all over the place and
Congressman to say that this is a big
problem I know we've it's been over a
year we're waiting for the Inspector
General to finish his report on the
Clinton email investigation but here's
what we do know he doesn't have
prosecutorial powers now I understand
that the Attorney General put this other
person in place and supposedly they can
work in conjunction with each other is
that going to get the job done let me
here are the facts as we know Clinton
violated 18 USC 793 miss handling
classified information top-secret
special access programming information
she deleted 33,000 emails she
acid-washed her hard drive with bleach
but she beat the crap out of her devices
or had an aide do it so that there's no
record of it is that not obstruction of
justice is that not a violation of law I
mean it's a simple yes annoying so
that's why it's so frustrating Comey
says that because Trump supposedly said
to Comey
man I hope you could find it to let
Flynn go that that is a potential
obstruction of justice but yet when he
was FBI director he didn't pursue any
obstruction of justice for Bleach
bidding emails that were under a
congressional subpoena those were the
critical emails and the Hillary Clinton
investigation and yet Jim Comey didn't
pursue that so how could you be so
zealous with everyone associated with
Trump's campaign but then bend over
backwards time and time again to not go
after obstruction or not go after
Hillary all right great job today this
is a big day finally now it's moving
thank you both